Leena trippa principal scientist working
at International Institute of tropical
agriculture in Nairobi Kenya first I
would like to thank the organizers for
inviting me to present our work and
topic of my presentation is application
of ginseng for improving and of
assistance
so why bananas because banana is one of
the major step frog
groaning more than 140 countries in the
subtropics and tropics that probably is
a fruit crop but in africa staple food
and it's ranked fourth most important
africa worldwide the total Chan is about
143 million tonnes and I've heard of
that that is produced in Africa cool
early by small farmers east is the
largest banana producing and consuming
region in Africa but even though it's
important crop it has a proof constraint
like diseases and pests are one of them
and I will say they are the constraint
so there are couple diseases like
multiple diseases black sigatoka
Fusarium built there is also bathroom
and while this is like a buncha topper
and the bananas requires and they are
pests like Nemeth and we so basically we
can apply biotechnology for the
improvement of Parana because the
conventional breeding of a several
challenges and for the sustained
intensification of crop productivity we
have to cook like um a conventional
technology technology capitation
so you know now the genome editing is
becoming P robust tool because it has
lot of promises but it's not a new
technology because they sure have the
added a home for very no I'm creating
variation and then selecting among the
natural variants
in 20 - missions were accelerated
chemicals and radiations and later on
the technology develop of gene targeted
mutations using zinc finger nucleases or
talons and later on the Crick cast 9
technology has been very successful in
several crops so we have our genome
editing in AI for banana banana has
different genotype it has a genome and
the B genome and there are so no so we
have established the technology with
different genotypes using the PDS which
is a fire change these are a steal and
if we create the mutation and me protein
then develop albino phenotype so it is
very easy to film thing the annotate
plant that's why we use as a marker gene
the PDS and then we have actually tested
them by by PCR with pan shift so you can
see here we can see clearly in lane
number 24 we can see that yes there is a
big deletion gee why they are too fast
there and further we have actually
checked the events using the sequencing
for in and we saw all sort of three all
three types of mutations like deletion a
dish and and the solutions so after it
stablishing
the genome editing system cookie system
for developing and and also some of the
gene discovery apart but it's technology
used for other traits as well like the
nutritional enhancement and a biotech
press tolerance so by focusing on
disease resistance but in my I mention
that there are so many diseases and and
50 a banana so critical need to develop
improved varieties of banana with the
spectrum and do resistance to diseases
and pests and the new breeding
technology like CRISPR gas 9 based
genome editing by that I put over
expressing of genes associated with
defense or editing the genes responsible
for the stability or pity factor of the
defense pathway so I will give sample
from that in walk we have between with
the virus the bananas tree acquires
bananas requires is plant pathogenic
virus of the chin papyrus basically it
is the full standard DNA reverse
transcript trust me virus and the pea is
a different viruses belonging to the
para retroviruses and is classified as
antigen what was integrated into the
home and once they are integrated into
the host genome readiness for the esv so
the joining sequences of EGA PSV are
integrated the genomic DNA of and so the
banana virus a super Nana she watched
three open reading frames the open read
one and was a small protein of unknown
is associated ons
o frame two encodes a protein of about
14 kilo Dalton which is involved in
theory on a sample three is the most
important because it in poly poop but he
was transcription and it actually and
goes like movement protein the court in
that a protease rnase edge and the
reverse transcriptase
and basically it is a four time genome
of a proxy a 7.3 27.8 okay but once it
is integrated into the banana chip there
are multiple copies of the viral genome
integrated aspect in direct tandem
repeat a single in the beach genome of
the off piranha
so banana has a genome and the beach you
know as far as only integrates in the so
basically which is like about seven kb
virus in pick up about 22 to 20 KB once
it's integrated into the banana genome
so when the virus is integrated tons
doesn't show any symptoms but under the
stress condition she can be the tissue
culture and the fascia conventional
reading can be the stresses but so the
says like like increase in temperature
or deficiency in water like drought
plant all considered them as so under
stress condition integrated virus pops
up is all and which is a function and
then the plant actually develop the same
jumps they show the the shape symptoms
and so naturally the piranhas strike
virus is transmitted through minibar of
the use of the infected landing material
so you can see from the minibar this
slide but epidemics are curved due to
the activation of the endogenous bananas
requires unders understanding it has
been one of the major challenge in
banana breeding as well as the
dissemination of the the heights and the
banana as the BG is
called plantains so we are planting
breeders cannot eat the germplasm which
has either one or more than one B genome
so they exploit digitally seon-ah which
is BB and normally breeders don't use it
in that program so it has important
traits it's like for the distance
because of the endogenous banana streets
integrate in the genome
oh that's why it is necessary to make a
be genome open and out 3 of the Act able
sequence or phase 3 for the strategy for
inactivation of the EBS V is we we
targeted the open reading frame of the
virus Oh open reading frame 1 and do
because they are small so and editing
happens at the simultaneously same time
then we expect a large issue and in the
open reading frame 3 we have we have
targeted only singles and then that
creates a small insertion or deletion
the so that is like a small in job and
if we have combined these two we works I
think that others should be activated
permanently we have designed the guide
RNA based on these three open reading
frame and we use the cast 9 which was
codon plan codon of his caste 9 and then
we have in the same because we Schmitt
based delivery of CRISPR cast mind
reeled and and all our guide is were
actually trip regulated by the rice our
youths promoter so we use the plunging
so the planting we used for this study
LT mark on Joe pile and we collected the
minerals from the field in Uganda these
pants were not showing any symptom in
the field condition and we we started in
vitro culture in the lab like like the
individual plans like useless and and
then we wanted to make sure his banana
has the endogenous benefit virus but if
he so much form of the virus so we have
done molecular characterization using
the foundation from fit various primers
based the NT the in feeding pattern we
have also done the southern analysis and
we form it was created and we didn't
find a normal form
and it was integrated as a multiple copy
either as it called indirect repeats so
after that we have generated the self
suspension of that plant in and used the
plasmid with that pine in the guide base
in there and use the agro bacterium
mediated transformation using this cell
suspension and generate the transgenic
plants then after that we have confirmed
the integration of the cache line
because these were any plans so the
cache my gene was integrated in the
plant and so you can see the PCR of the
showing the gas not in presence of the
gas my gene and also it shows the region
and it ate plants well as the portage
potted plants and we didn't see you know
typically my friends being the all-time
conscience
non annotated ones and the
a glance then we have shot Annalise
plans using easy are we have target was
the so we have designed the primers
actually for the top each side flanking
the open reading frame one and two
because those ones like about 198 base
pairs apart if the time key
simultaneously then you were expecting a
deletion of 108 and we saw that band
shift analysis and several of the
samples didn't show any benches that
means that either they won only pins all
the indels were all will not be able to
go on the on the job so we also did that
be 708 a for once and then we have that
the different fragments which means were
small indulge in Impa after that we did
the sequencing so we did the sequencing
for the the s 1 and s 2 so we unrefined
180 be base pair fragment covering the
two nuts and and then we sequenced 10
Rockets of the clone for each event and
17 out of me even sequence should target
a mistake and out of 17 actual 15 showed
the mutations at both days and then when
the Transvaal actually together we saw
in many of them asana 128 deletion so it
was a big deletion and only 2 out of 20
even chose the homogeneous mutation
knocking all the copies of that because
they are multiple copies that was our
aim after that the sequence for the ok
the s3 again enter again and clone and
then sequence and 14 out of 20 even sin
the s3 also showed the the mutation
and in this case the the mutations were
small in those the addition or deletion
or the replacement and and then food
even actually lead reading frames kids
without with the potential to inactivate
EPS V so after the sequencing we have
confirmed yes these were added early and
then took eight edited events for the
glasshouse evaluation along with the
with the poll which were advocates so in
the figure the first figure is the
control and the remaining are the
additive events and trusting that cuts
through the motorists so we didn't give
the water to these plants for two weeks
and after two weeks these runs the plant
actually a streak symptom and only two
events of the added and shows slide sets
the other six out of eight evens tested
Dinge any symptom bananas drink of
disease oh then we further tested it by
PCR for the presence of the virus
symptomatic and the non sentiment but
and we didn't find any amplification in
the launching we also read the qPCR
check and in this our control was the
Cavendish because Cavendish has Triple A
so in that case there is no integrated
but required we have seen rule and our
AB six edited events were similar to the
control console that those six events
had activation of the virus so
asymptomatic plants indoors in all the
openings and I was curious why the to
even show the symptoms so they even two
simple events had indels OPA
reading frame 1 openly different too but
they didn't have any symptom in the
opening treat which ended that the open
reading frames pre may play a crucial
role in symptom development so big as I
explained before open reading frame 3
and coats of poly protein and which is
cheap post krishna by a protease in
buddhist functional or three encoded
proteins and our target for chips in the
protease so best be if we make this
party is not known we are making all of
the proteins non-functional so and also
see the multiple knockout in all the
three pairs can completely prevent lead
to activation because that's what in the
six the aspartic events so in summary we
got about 95% mutation efficiency using
the multiple guide RNA so with all the
three colonies we saw the patient enough
events out of the 20 tests take eighty
five percent surely knows in the in the
target one and the target 270 plus with
the smooth all guide RNA at the topic
tree doctor 20 tested only two homage
invitation of isn't good enough we
further tested for the uniformity and i
stable patients so we did was we took
these two events we multiplied then
through tissue culture for several
patient then we test their different
leaves for the mutation and find out
that the mutations were safe different
leaves and we also test print daughter
plants and and they showed also the same
in does confirming that they do taste a
uniform at people
the off-target analysis for off-target
analysis
I've actually blocked any plus the path
is tied with the a genome which is the
mosaic you mean are the reference genome
and also the BG and we found about 58 of
target sites in the a genome and that
beach you know sites in the beach you
know matching about 63 to 95 percent but
these are like a few tickets then
further we have several potential of
targets size nine different ones and we
only saw the one point mutation and one
putative of target locus in just one so
our result a no property for potential
of target the mutation now if we
actually have a G to knock out the
endogenous integrate bananas require so
now what we are doing is actually
proving the parents so the planting they
have used is a triploid but the parents
finder deployed or the tetraploid so we
are busy actually improving these
Reploids
and improper so that they can be fast we
get which will be the free of the banana
street chorus and and then after
crossing so our parents will be
transgenic because we have used a
plasmid page to learn through agro
bacterium but once we will cross these
parents then the hybrids will be non
because we will segregate them and we
will look for the mutation but the each
has good it can and no integration of
country now we are and banana for fungal
and
prion diseases and I will tell you about
what we are but a bacterial gentleman ah
this is a serious problem in East Africa
because it's effective banana product
and the food so here is all wonderful
twin bananas in East Africa so - I did a
target heading of banana and for the
bacterial resistance we have conducted
the comparative transcriptomic analysis
and the musa bath and the wild type and
and is resistant to the peasant Mona's
wealth assisted banana and we have
identified the target based on the
temperature expressed gene and now we
are creating the mutations either in the
susceptance aught Porter genes and the
transcriptional factors involved
negative regulator of the defense part
so if you one example we have used the
DMR snakes which is a downy mildew
resistance slope when dependent
oxygenase that act as a suppressor of
this gene just did actually in few other
crops as well
it is up regulated during pathogen
inspection so if we can me this gene
non-functional then the plant should
develop the transistor that's why we
have edited our bananas the knockout of
the TMR six we have we have used them
are six will be used to guide our and
mr6 sodium are six mutants of bananas
then we have tested them against the the
bacterial resistance by in all his plans
with bacteria and our additive plants
some of the aggregate plants didn't show
any is he seemed as the old what type
bananas develop the disease finally
completely circum its weeks time so now
we will be we will be testing further
these plants in the Glass House and
condition result so finally for
concludes again now is it was staple
food crops grown in subtropics and
tropics its production is largely
constrained by diseases and so therefore
there is a need to develop another
varieties with multiple and durable
resistance against Oh Chris podcast
annoyed bass genome editing hi banana in
our lab and currently I think this pain
disease resistance in bananas and its
application amonst rated for permanently
activating the bananas tree quarries
which is integrated into the B genome of
now and currently research is focusing
for application of genome editing for
developing resistance to bacterial and
fungal death in the acknowledged my team
with the general Valentine's samsara
mark and also the is lava and our by
informatician two shots are also
operator from UC Davis who had asked
with designing the guide RNA and and the
construct for piranhas frequent use meal
Iran and and a colleague from the Gates
Foundation Jim Lawrence and for advice
on the panel at forest project
thank you very for listening and I will
be take any question if you have